hey guys so do you remember the drone
that I flew into the tree well this is
the drone that I flew into the tree they
were able to retrieve it
so I've got it back my dad dried it all
out retrieved the SD card and now we're
gonna try to fly this little beast
oh man the drone was flying so good I
did a couple of the intelligent flight
modes
I've yet to do it by myself I went to
DJI and they showed me a couple of the
features I think I told you guys about
that briefly but I tried the tap to fly
and I also did the follow me mode and a
couple of things and my battery died and
then I couldn't do anything else so that
was that but I'm sure you guys at the
drone does in fact work after being
stuck in a tree for several days now I'm
hanging out with Bo and Manny they yes
Watson supposed to show you the drone
does in fact work see you guys in the
next video hope you guys enjoyed all
your videos they were so much fun but
man I spent so much I'm editing so I
hope you guys enjoy them see ya later
bye
you